Hello à vous les mentalos ! Aujourd'hui on va parler de PNL.
Enlevez tout de suite les doigts de votre clavier pour ce commentaire, car non je ne parle pas du chanteur, mais bien de programmation neurolinguistique.
On va utiliser la PNL pour pratiquer une sorte d'auto-encrage contre le stress.
L'idée de cette vidéo est que vous puissiez vous sentir plus zen... sur commande !
[musique du générique]
Un des outils les plus puissants de la PNL est pour moi l'ancrage.
Même si elle est à la base souvent utilisée pour les autres, son utilité est encore plus puissante quand on s'en sert sur soi.
Aujourd'hui nous allons créer un ancrage, ce qui est différent d'un pattern d'ailleurs.
Pour pouvoir descendre à un niveau de stress et retrouver une émotion positive.
C'est très simple !
Vous allez commencer par ce qu'on appelle le conditionnement positif.
Donc vous vous mettez assis ou allongé , où vous voulez.
Dans un endroit calme où vous vous sentez bien.
Utilisez des techniques de relaxation pour vous détendre ou de respiration comme celle dont j'avais parlé dans la vidéo sur la concentration.
Détendez-vous le plus possible.
Vous allez bientôt déterminer votre point d'ancrage, mais vous devez d'abord déterminer quelle émotion positive vous souhaitez mettre dans cet ancrage.
Ça peut être l'énergie, la joie, la motivation, ce que vous voulez !
Et choisissez un souvenir où vous aviez vécu cette émotion là.
Attention, ce n'est pas forcément un souvenir en action.
Par exemple, moi un grand souvenir de joie récent c'est quand on m'a remis le trophée au Space.
C'est la sensation quand j'ai eu le trophée en lui-même.
Au-delà même du moment physique.
Vous comprenez ce que je veux dire ?
Essayez de retrouver l'émotion telle que vous la ressentiez, avec le souvenir adéquate.
Décidez ensuite de votre ancrage.
Alors il peut être physique, comme se toucher le ventre comme ça.
Ça peut être aussi, mettre le doigt sur sa bague et la faire tourner pour ceux qui ont une bague.
Parce que sinon c'est moins pratique...!
Ça peut être prendre ou voir un objet précis.
Ça peut même être un gout ou une odeur.
Si vous avez déjà déterminer un jour si vous étiez plutôt visuel, kinesthésique, auditif...vous pouvez vous en servir pour choisir l'ancrage.
Alors c'est vraiment essentiel de bien faire ce choix, parce que c'est là que vous allez placer cette émotion.
C'est un horcrux en fait, ni plus ni moins... [rires]
Maintenant vous allez déclencher le stimuli.
Le point d'ancrage, donc, tel que vous l'avez choisi.
Si mon émotion c'était la joie, via la remise de trophée, et que mon point d’ancrage était la bague,
je vais dans mon état de relaxation commencer à faire ce stimuli là, en revivant le moment mentalement.
Donc vous restez dans cette phase de relaxation et vous revivez pleinement ce souvenir les yeux fermés, vous le visualisez.
Revivez le réellement, prenez tout le temps qu'il vous faut. vous n’êtes pas pressé.
Vous pouvez le refaire plusieurs fois, en boucle comme ça.
Mais ressentez sincèrement l'émotion et associez le toujours au stimuli.
Et vous venez de réaliser votre ancrage !
Votre auto-ancrage !
A chaque fois que vous allez déclencher ce stimuli, vous vous retrouverez plus détendu, et vous retrouverai cette émotion par réflexe.
Il est possible que l'ancrage ne soit pas assez profond la première fois.
Ça peut arriver, même, ça arrive souvent, pour ne pas vous le cacher !
Alors, n'hésitez pas à refaire toutes ces étapes régulièrement, au départ, ça peut être tous les jours ou une fois par semaine.
Prenez soin à chaque fois d’être en conditionnement positif, et de arder la même émotion, le même souvenir, et le même stimuli.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. J'espère qu'elle vous sera utile !
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour durant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]